[Music]
today we're gonna be talking about if
you don't know where you're going it
doesn't matter how fast you get there
and when I go speak with companies and
organizations and developers and
operators and executives we want to
start doing everything better and faster
and stronger and secure and more
reliable and us like who's heard this
about a million times yes okay who heard
the devs in the house who are the office
in the house whose management executives
yeah okay we all want to do the thing
right because who like who wants to be
awesome all of us who wants to suck at
things okay good trick question I was
like who's just raising their hands cuz
exercise we want to do everything better
because we got into this because Tech is
exciting and fun and we get to make
things and be creative and watch like
watch the lights light up and do hello
world and make things awesome but it's
tough when we aren't necessarily sure
what that means right except also
sometimes that's great because we
understand and were the experts and we
know what that looks like so how how is
it that we do this so that's what we get
to talk about today where are we going
how do we actually improve performance
and how tricky is that word right
performance isn't is a tough one how do
we make it a carrot not just a stick how
should we measure it why should we
actually care and and then at the end
kind of like what is this culture thing
and how do we actually measure it so
that we can then make it better so let's
start with where are we going who hears
heard of maturity models do we know what
maturity models are I'm so excited to
who's not heard of our new model do we
want to
quick recap do we want to recap anyway
okay so maturity models are this
wonderful thing that help explain like
where we are and they're usually like
predefined levels by the way they're
usually made up by someone trying to
sell us something they all go to level 5
do we know why they go to level 5 most
of them go to level 5 because we all
have five fingers it's true it's true
okay who here has played World of
Warcraft fine who here has a friend
who's played World of Warcraft yes okay
here we go
when World of Warcraft first came out
this was like the land right so even if
you have even if all of your friends
have played we all like get this right
it's a map when it first came out it
went to lake level 60 you could like
roll a bunch of character you could
create a bunch of characters I just said
Road clearly I played World of Warcraft
currently I just stopped playing World
of Warcraft because it finished like
work it's cool job stuff you could be
like a mage or like all this cool stuff
it went to level 60 you can have a bunch
of tools you can have a bunch of
technologies so let's create ourselves a
maturity model how do you feel about
this let's pretend we're executives
let's create a maturity model how do we
feel about this yay okay you're my
people this is great okay so but we
don't have very much time so our
maturity models are you only going to go
to level 3 so first level is gonna be
level good and we're gonna like conquer
land on the left second maturity model
is going to be level and we'll go to
level 40 sounds good okay
second level is going to be level great
and it'll be all of the land on the left
and half the land on the right and we'll
go to level 50 third level will be
called level amazing and we will conquer
conquer all of the lands sound good yay
okay so we progress we all move forward
we've conquered all the lands and at the
end of this exercise what happens
we get a gold star on her forehead
everyone got start for it
participate go through her forehead we
collect our front bonus check and we pay
our consultants
congratulations okay
now let's fast forward several years and
what happens this is now the land in
World of Warcraft the land has changed
the landscape has changed by the way you
can now go to level 110 the technology
has changed the competition has changed
y'all you can have pets now does anyone
care that we got our gold star no for
honey we got to level 60 if we go out
and try to fight what's gonna happen
we're gonna get our butts kicked our
competition has changed our customers
expectations have changed and like this
is a fun silly example and story but
it's also very relevant for technology
right so the challenge with maturity
models particularly as we talk about
developing and delivering technology and
features for customers whether they're
internal end-users or external end-users
is that it doesn't help us actually
address what matters oh that was some
magical forwarding they tell us that
we're done when we reach a predefined
destination and the whole rest of the
world keeps addressing and answering
what matters and what's important they
also tell us and leaders to stop
dedicating resources once we've arrived
by their a resources aren't just money
it's time its attention it's education
it's training it's paying attention to
what our customers need and want
they also tell us that we all follow the
exact same path to success
remember our super fund made at maturity
model it said that we had to explore
that land in the exact same order now if
we think about this in terms of
technology transformation getting our
teams better faster delivering think
about the organizations that we're in
right now think about all the teams that
are working on and delivering technology
do they all look the same
probably not so their next step forward
will it look exactly the same probably
not and the next step and the next step
in the next step again probably not so
how do we expect a step by step by step
map and prescriptive path to make sense
for something that's so complex
now maturity models tell us that
technology is a checklist to just be
completed and when we're done we're done
and we move on to something else but we
got into this game because it's fun and
it's exciting and we get to keep
discovering what's new now listen I
understand I fundamentally understand
why maturity models are good and why
they're comforting is because it lets me
get that someone else has been where
I've been and that they know what comes
next but if if they point me too far
into the future that's that's not
helpful okay so thanks Nicole you just
like brought down the room sad trombone
so how do we actually get there what's
helpful what's helpful is to focus on a
constraint by constraint I basically
just mean like what's holding me back
what's the hurdle for each team
focus on that fix it
execute well and completely I make it
sound simple it's not I know it's a
challenge but that's also why we rely on
our expertise and on our experts and
also on our community one thing I really
really love about the DevOps movement
that I've seen over the last decade is
that we really rely on each other to
move forward ok so then where are we
going a direction is helpful I didn't
say we have to fly blind we should know
at least what direction we should be
facing ok so then what direction is that
and the number one question I get so
often is is there one metric that
matters can anyone guess the right
answer here no sorry
Oh your executive that no there's not
but if I have to pick something this
would be it it would be software
delivery performance and it's not one
metric but it is four of them and they
tend to hang out together they'll go
drink tea together and they have a
little knitting circle and they chill
and they throw darts
now here's what I mean when I say
software delivery performance I mean
some throughput and stability measures
throughput is speed so I'm talking about
deployment frequency how often you push
code I'm also talking about lead time
for changes code commit to code running
in production and then I'm talking about
stability stability is time to restore
service and change fail rate now if
someone challenged me earlier this week
and I really appreciate her doing that
because she said why are you only
focusing on things that are easy to
measure not really quickly I'd say these
aren't necessarily easy but she had a
really fantastic point because there are
so many things that are important and
why are you focusing on this I'm not
focusing on this at the exclusion of
other things like culture and people and
quality but this is important for
few things first of all this focuses on
the performance of software delivery and
notice that I'm measuring things that
are in tension so often people have told
us that we can't have both speed and
stability right has anyone heard that
for things to be stable or safe we have
to slow down yeah right we've kind of
heard this it's been whispered in dark
alleys right we found over five years of
research and 30,000 data points these
actually move together and when I say
move together I mean I take all these
data points do we want like a stats
tangent really quick can I start out for
a second okay yes okay I take all the
data points and I throw them in a hopper
very technical term throw it in the
hopper and I do a cluster analysis which
means I want to see how they cluster
together so I see them all like kind of
grouped together and statistically
meaningful ways and then a gap so
they're statistically different from
another group and then a group and then
a gap and then a group I'm real creative
so I call them high performers and
medium performers and low performers but
what that means when they group together
I'm seeing the speed and stability
measures move together the high
performers are doing everything well the
medium performers like we're seeing like
the middle group hang out together and
some people are like on the struggle bus
together down at the bottom we see
movement together
there aren't trade-offs I think that's
important so if you walk away with only
one thing have it be that speed and
stability are possible together okay so
then what's what's next some people
wonder where they might fall this is my
eye chart sorry it's real small this
comes from the 2018 accelerate state of
DevOps report so when we take this very
data-driven approach where do people
fall we see elite performers so this is
the highest group the high performers
can push code on demand
léa time for changes again code commit
to code running in production less than
an hour it's getting it all the way
through your pipeline time to restore
service again less than an hour do you
know what makes me super excited about
that that means that when you have an
emergency something breaks your regular
process looks very very much like your
emergency process you're not skipping
tests everything goes through change
fail rate it's between zero and 15
percent and by the way historically that
actually looks very close to the two
three five percent mark compare that to
our low performers these are needy and
numbers so we do have a range here we
see deploy frequency between once a week
and once a month lead time for changes
between one month and six months time to
restore service between one week and one
month this is where we're seeing a
difference right and then our change
fail rate is between forty six and sixty
percent now if you take a look at this
you think about where your team might
fall if you don't see yourself on this
chart don't be discouraged so often I'll
get people contact me and I'll say but
I'm not here this isn't my industry it
doesn't apply first of all it all
industries are represented highly
regulated field show up in elite
performers crazy cowboy startups or in
low performers were everywhere but don't
be discouraged because everyone can
achieve high performance we just need to
start working and everyone can do it we
can all work together and get there okay
but how right how do we get there one
does not just walk into high performance
so how do we get there right
DevOps or you know whatever you want to
call it technology transformation
whatever whatever your leadership team
likes just do your little find and
replace it's a cross-functional
community dedicated to building evolving
and operating secure resilient systems
at scale
it can include so many job titles tasks
and roles but I think the part that's
important is that we work together we
automate we reduce toil and we deliver
value for whoever our end users are so
this is a summary of my research over
the last five years and right now
everyone is like what girl so let's
think of it this way
we have a cultural aspect we have a
tooling and automation aspect and we
have some process it really breaks down
into these things okay we can manage
this right we feel okay we can have we
heard culture is important okay we can
do culture but wait we're at a tech
conference tell me that we've heard that
tooling is important okay we're good
here and process right we need to serve
okay okay now we're back here's what we
see so technical practices and
continuous delivery that's at the bottom
we're gonna break this down by the way
anytime you see an arrow this is a
predictive relationship lean management
and lean product development these are
going to be some processes this arrow
see this SDO performance that's our
speed and stability and availability
okay so all of these like lead into this
stuff quick like tangent in the middle
outsourcing is bad who's surprised
what's the price okay good
cloud infrastructure helps that's a huge
driver PS if you do it right the things
I love about culture we can see autonomy
helps drive culture westrom
organizational culture we'll talk about
it drives job satisfaction look down
here at the bottom identity if we really
love our work smart investments decrease
burnout decreased appointment pain
decrease rework in S are real and we
call this toil right we're decreasing
toil
and it helps us with organizational
performance and at the very very back at
the very far left we see
transformational leadership has anyone
here had a really really great leader
manager mentor someone in the organ or
even just like a really dope team lead
that somehow made your work amazing and
you were somehow kicking out way more
work than you ever did before yeah so
this makes sense right because their
influence flows through and magnifies
and amplifies all the work okay so it
looks crazy but it all does boil down to
culture and tooling and process and
we've got some great evidence to help us
point to what to look for now again
though sometimes people will look at
this and they're like where do I even
start this is like 37 things let's think
back identify your constraint
what's your team's biggest hurdle focus
there start there eliminate that
constraint so in Theory of Constraints
we call that elevating the constraint
once it's no longer the thing that's in
your way focus on the next constraint
okay now the next big question I get is
how do I measure performance the biggest
mistakes I often see are these focusing
on outputs versus outcomes the
difference between individual and local
measures versus team and global measures
so let's look through some examples here
lines of code this is the best example I
have four outputs versus outcomes it's
funny because sometimes I bring this up
as an example and so often people like
lines of code who still gets asked about
lines of code I get asked about lines of
code every at least every month almost
every other week so lines of code is
dumb
and here's the best examples sometimes
we were like well more lines of code is
gonna be good one ways of code is not
good who already knows this we all
already knows see you all my people this
is a smart room because write more code
just gives us more to maintain write
bloated software slows things down
higher maintenance costs higher cost of
change maybe less is better but like who
has seen this ridiculous thing worse
like someone comes up with this right
exactly the immediate hand where someone
comes up with this amazingly amazingly
clever one line of code that two weeks
later like no one can read no one can
interpret we have no idea what happened
sometimes the best answer is to delete
code right or change a business process
so that you don't need code lines of
code just it's not a great proxy for
things it's it's difficult right
that's an output it's a measure of
output but it doesn't tell us what we
accomplished by the way that's why we
focus on software delivery performance
right because that's it's at the end ok
so let's talk about velocity then so for
some background when we were in agile
land problems we brake problems down to
two stories which then we assign points
and we estimate effort to complete these
we're all familiar with this right ok
great
at the end of the Sprint we assign or
the total points are signed up by the
customer this is velocity by the way T
is a capacity planning tool we shouldn't
be using this to measure productivity
over the years teams have often used
this to measure productivity but it's
not great as a measure of productivity
and here's why velocity is a relative
measure it's not an absolute measure
it's relative to the team to the tasks
they're doing to the context that
they're working in we should never be
comparing teams on their velocity we can
also game it by inflating estimates
which is understandable right we want to
make sure that we have our targets this
last point is the most important though
we want to be again thinking about
outcomes what's the goal what are the
teams working on if I'm working on a
team and I have points that I want to
accomplish and you're working on a team
and you have something that you want to
accomplish what happens if there's
something that needs to be accomplished
for the entire organization it requires
us working together look I helped you I
got points I got to finish so we want to
be thinking about outcomes not outputs
finally utilization utilization is good
but only up into a point because more
isn't necessarily better it doesn't
allow for slack and we all know that we
always have unplanned work right and if
anything when people come back to me and
they debate this point I'll just point
back to math Q Theory tells me that as
utilization approaches 100 percent lead
times approach infinity once we hit
higher and higher and higher levels of
utilization your teams take longer to
get work done I can think about this
myself the longer my to-do list gets the
the longer it takes me to get anything
right okay now why why should we care
about any of this why do we care why do
we care about delivering software faster
why do we care about it being faster and
more stable here's why teams that
deliver more often when I compare those
elite performers and those low
performers we see 46 times more frequent
code deployments over 2,500 times faster
from commits to deploy seven times lower
change fail rate and over 2,600 times
faster time to recover from incidents it
lets us get our features to customers
faster it lets us recover from downtime
it lets us patch faster we can get out
our compliance and regulatory changes
better
and faster it also makes it just easier
and safer to push our code lets us get
back to the fun part of what it is that
we do it also helps us contribute to the
organization whether that means money
commercial goals productivity
profitability market share or
non-commercial goals because we care
about more than just the bottom line we
care about things like effectiveness
efficiency and customer satisfaction and
I really love the shift that we've been
seeing in the broader industry over the
last several years to things like
corporate social responsibility and we
know that delivering software better
helps us achieve these goals for bonus
points we also see that elite performers
the highest performers see 50% higher
market cap growth over the previous
three years now as a little asterisk
that analysis was only available for
those companies that are publicly traded
on the New York Stock Exchange
now why else do we care this also
contributes to quality we see high
performers are able to do more new work
now what do I mean by new work they
don't have to do as much rework or
unplanned work we get to do more novel
work more fun development now when I say
development I don't just mean developers
I was a sysadmin for years sometimes I
want to create new infrastructure I want
to do more creating of whatever it is
that I'm building that's new work as
well I don't want to have to keep fixing
his stuff that I've done before this was
the part that matters so much to me it
also helps us make our work better it
contributes to happier people because we
don't just want to burn out all the time
the thing I love is at the prom
of DevOps makes work better it decreases
burnout and by the way burnout isn't
just being tired burnout is when we
don't love what we used to love anymore
about our work
making smart investments in tech and
process actually combats this it also
helps decrease deploy pain that's like
that panic when you push into prod
you're like please just work you know
that awful meme that's hilarious but
it's funny cuz it's true with like the
girl in the burning house worked fine in
DevOps problem now it helps get rid of
that also gives us better job
satisfaction and when I say job
satisfaction our research into job
satisfaction wasn't just I like my work
it's my work makes good use of my skills
and abilities and I have the tools I
need to do my job so it's like I get to
do dope stuff we also see higher Net
Promoter Score from employees so they
love what they do and they tell everyone
else about it and a better
organizational culture speaking of I
keep saying our culture who here has a
definition of our culture
who here has like three or definitions
of our culture
whoever sick of raising their hand we
always talk about organizational culture
when we talk about DevOps and I think
it's because for years we were doing
this technology thing and promising it
would make a difference and to be frank
it never did and when I started doing
this research people told me I was crazy
I actually almost got kicked out of my
ph.d program because for 40 years we had
research showing that investments in
technology didn't matter have we all
heard this whole like IT as a cost
center that's
but here's why it was because we used to
just like by tech and then walk away and
expect like the magical fairy to show up
the problem is that if anyone else can
just buy tech and walk away and do
nothing else that doesn't make you
magically better than all of your
competitors it doesn't help you make
things awesome for your customer or your
end user what we have to do is we have
to find ways to differentiate ourselves
and that requires technology and process
and culture and people and then the
magical fairy shows up and so culture is
really really important because that's
what allows people who are fundamentally
different and diverse in background and
technology and and skill set to talk
together and make these incredibly
complex diverse distributed systems work
in these ways that we've never seen
before
and so when we started doing this work
we reached back into some of the other
literature and found this great research
by a sociologist named Ron westrom now
he was doing research into high risk
complex systems where if something
breaks real bad things happen so I'm
talking healthcare nuclear power
aviation notice that there when things
bad things happen people die like
immediately now to be fair that's also
kind of true in tech right because we're
also working in systems that power
healthcare and aviation and these very
very high risk systems I remember
pushing into prod and we almost had to
evacuate an ICU when a backup failed and
it failed horribly so we've also had
these situations happen where something
bad happens in our stomachs not so this
organizational culture
Maps up to so much of what we see when
we talk about having a culture that
values information flow and transparency
and learning from failure and bridging
across silos and so when we found this
we were like this might be a great way
to talk about and measure and think
about a DevOps culture right is this
kind of resonating okay so let's look
about the path at the pathological one
power-oriented
its tip if I'd buy low cooperation we
shoot the messenger we don't want to
hear bad news responsibilities are
shirked bridging is discouraged failure
scapegoating novelties crushed okay who
here has a friend that works here okay a
couple of friends here across our
research we've seen I want to say about
25-30 percent fall here and it's highly
correlated with low performers
bureaucratic is very rural oriented now
to be fair this isn't necessarily a bad
thing
bureaucratic cultures are meant to
optimize for fairness okay
modest cooperation among these very very
different teams messengers are neglected
if someone brings me brings me bad news
I just kind of ignore it I don't want to
hear it lalala narrowly defined
responsibilities bridging is tolerated
failure leads to justice novelty leads
to problems I'm here as a friend who
works here okay we've got some hands I
want to say about 55 percent of
respondents hit here and it's highly
correlated with meeting performers
bridging oh when we bridge across teams
so like dev bridges to ops bridges to
testing or even bridges to something
like marketing oh the question was what
do I mean by bridging okay now the final
and generative or performance oriented
culture high cooperation high
cooperation among teams that that are
like traditionally very different
messengers are trained so what do I mean
by this I I want people to bring me bad
news because then when I know it that I
can fix it risks are shared
bridging is encouraged fail your least
inquiry when I read that I think of
blameless post-mortems right and the
novelty is implemented who here has a
friend or is lucky enough to work
somewhere like this who here has no
friends I love this because it mirrors
some of the research done by Google's
teams a few years ago from project
Aristotle the background to some of this
research was they were wondering what
would make the perfect team and I if I
recall correctly honestly the hypothesis
moving into this was that the perfect
team would have the perfect mix of
skills like technical skills what they
found instead was that the number one
driver was psychological safety they
feel safe to take risks and be
vulnerable in front of each other
followed by dependability structure and
clarity meaning and impact it comes down
to team dynamics it comes down to the
culture that's what really drives
impacts and teams and I think it's
particularly interesting because as I
refer back to westerns organizational
culture the thing that was particularly
interesting is in addition to defining
and predicting outcomes it also helped
explain what happens when things go
wrong
how often do systems fail all the time
because we're working with highly highly
complex systems so what else we see is
that failure in these complex systems
will always happen there's no way to
guarantee against all failure
so in these systems we often see that
human error is the starting point and so
when we do blameless post-mortems we
want to understand where to move forward
so how can we get people better
information and then how can we detect
and limit
failure modes how can we build our
systems better I love this this picture
in this example R in Daniels was at Etsy
for a while um is anyone familiar with
this story this story is dope so at Etsy
they actually reward people for finding
fantastic failures in the system and why
is this it's because you have uncovered
an opportunity to build more resiliency
into the system so R in here was awarded
the three armed sweater are we familiar
with XE XE is a is a marketplace where
users can sell their their handmade
goods one of their users knitted them a
three arm sweater and so every year they
have an award show and and ran writes
about this on their blog and it's on
failure and resilience and and it really
is an honor and it's very unintentional
but the better you can kind of bring
down the system it uncovers fantastic
opportunities for them and so this is
where we're R in wins and is awarded the
three armed sweater and and Kripa
krishnan talks about this at cloud
operations for dirt operations so dirt
is disaster resilience testing for dirt
style events to be successful an
organization first needs to accept
system and process failures as a means
of learning remember back how learning
was an opportunity or failure was an
opportunity to learn we design tests
that require engineers from several
groups who might not normally work
together to interact with each other
that way should a real large-scale
disaster ever strike these people will
already have strong working
relationships I love that as well right
bridging across teams breaking down
silos
so in conclusion direction matters more
than maturity I know everyone loves to
benchmark themselves against where they
are and know what level we're on but we
always need to keep getting better what
happens if we get to level 5 and a few
years later suddenly the industry has
magically decided that we get to a level
8 we just need to keep moving forward
and getting better second we can have it
all or at least speed and stability
DevOps culture and practices have a
measurable impact on performance quality
and culture and culture can be measured
and changed one more plug if any of this
research or information was interesting
to you at all the data collection for
the 2019 state of DevOps report is open
right now and is and will be open until
May 3rd
[Music]